[Musik]
wow ich habe mich so krass auf diese
herbsthoodie sommerwinter Übergangszeit
gefreut wo man einfach wieder so cool St
en kann lange Hose T-Shirt zpper don't
know aber irgendwie fühlt sich so an als
ob man direkt von Sommer auf Winter
gegangen ist dieses Jahr es ist
arschkalt ka Strike direkt zurück ne
hätt dich einmal rum einmal ganz kurz
sage ich hier Wetter passt mir nicht so
ganz der Übergang
plappen ich bin in irgendwas
reingefahren ich habe ein Platten
bekommen sch das an
überall liegen anscheinend wieder
Scherben rum und ich habe wieder nicht
gesehen
Idiot Familienfoto ich SAS so bodenlos
Alter einfach seinem Hund Pulli
anziehen what the [__] d Ich schieben
muss ist auch
bodenlos einfachen Platten das ist mein
dritter Platten dieses
[Musik]
Jahr der Herbst ist in Deutschland so
eine korrupte Jahreszeit ne man denkt an
so bisschen kühl aber mit Sonne ja fahr
noch weiter auf dem Fahrradweg man denkt
so an Sonne bisschen schöne Blätter auf
dem Boden Kürbisse Tee aber man hat
einfach nur Regen und im Herbst
Fahrradfahren heißt einfach nur zu
versuchen nicht auf die Fresse zu
fliegen diger es ist so matschig
überall sind Fützen und wenn ich dann
auch über diese Fahrradwege fahre die
früher noch nicht so wie hier geil auf
der Straße waren sondern so 20 cm breit
auf dem burürgersteig dann waren da nur
diese glipschigen Backsteine Bo hat
gerade schon wieder NAT erfahrung hab
aber als coolen Drifter einfach
abgestempelt in der
[Musik]
Innenstadt Francesco me der hat eine
Überraschung für mich ja aber die ist
jetzt auch nicht da Francesco hat mir
gerade verraten was die Überraschung ist
und zwar kommt ein Kollege den ich
länger nicht gesehen habe jetzt als Gast
gleich vorbei wir haben uns überlegt den
zu verarschen indem wir ihm sagen e
Francesco super krass coolen neuen
Eistee aber wir packen da Whiskey mit
rein fr füt jetzt hier vorne sch mal
whisy rein ins Glas D wenn er gleich
durch die Tür kommt und sich hier
hinsetzt und Fran fragt was er trinken
will FST du nur noch Wasser oben
drauf
wirklich musst probieren
zuckerininer ne ich will e nicht ein kin
Schluck
ne ext versteckte Kamera
auf unterm letzten Vlog kamen einige
Kommentare warum der Titel mein neues
Auto war obwohl die Szene nur irgendwie
so 3 Sekunden im im Vlog waren ihr müsst
euch einfach überlegen dass in so einem
Vlog unfassbar viel passiert und wenn
ich all das in den Titel schreiben würde
was im Video passiert müsste der Titel
halt so 200 Wörter lang sein deswegen
ich weiß no nicht wie das heute heißt
wahrscheinlich irgendwas mit Schlafen
ich habe mich beim Schlafen gefilmt oder
so und was ich auch einige Male unter
mein Vlogs gelesen habe we ey Luca das
sind gar keine richtigen Vlogs weil das
bei dir voll häufig über Z D Tage
verteilt ist so ein Video auch für euch
ganz kurz Z Erklärung Vlog steht für
vide Log also vide Logbuch das heißt man
spricht auf Video einfach auf was man
macht da ist nicht festgeschrieben dass
es jetzt irgendwie 24 Stunden sein
sollen oder eine Woche oder keine Ahnung
was und da in meinem Leben so wenig
passiert an einem Tag teile ich halt
häufiger mal
auf ich fahre gerade wier fah also mehr
almann geht nicht ne Helm auf Fahne
vorne am Fahrrad so einen komischen
Übergang zwiebelu da mit so Dings und
noch Taschen am Lenker ir so ein Ding
die hat auch Taschen am Lenker äh am
Keller kofferra wie heißt das
[Musik]
Ding jusf und ich schauen uns jetzt eine
Immobilie an
moin für eventuelle Tätigkeiten ab
Januar und dann wird s auch eventuell
ein bisschen was ändern hier auf dem
Youtubekanal wenn das alles gut läuft ja
drücken wir
[Musik]
die Freundin hat mir letztens gesagt
dass ich es extrem weird findet dass ich
meine Boxer Shorts nie Falte und auch
meine Socken in der Ankleide nie
irgendwie vernünftig zusammenlegt warum
sollte ich das tun
das ist doch einfach nur
Zeitverschwendung ich falte es doch eh
wieder auseinander genauso auch diese
Leute die frische Handtücher fein
säuberlich übereinander sortieren im
Badezimmer und zusammengefaltet
dahinlegen warum diger ihr müsst doch eh
wieder auseinander Falten ist einfach
Zeitverschwendung das ist einfach der
größte
hassmoment man weiß einfach man hat
reingeschissen irgendein verdammtes
Taschentuch war mit in der
[Musik]
Waschmaschine
ich war einfach gerade bei meinem
Hausarzt weil ich seit ein paar Wochen
sehr starken Schwindel habe und er
meinte dann dass das vom Nacken kommt
und hat mir dann fünf Spritzen in den
Nacken gehauen ich blende euch hier mein
Video ein das habe ich gemacht als ich
da am Treppenhaus runtergelaufen bin da
sieht man das so ein bisschen und jetzt
habe ich Hal glaub ich im noch irgendwie
we nicht fühlt sich einfach an als wenn
ich die ganze Zeit so könnerkissen
hinten drauf hätte ich hoffe mal das
wird jetzt
BD
klar das dem Salzstreuer ne mach öter
kann man eigentlich kaufen sehr
flauschig
kan allerdings endlich mal weg sind
können wir nun endlich zum eigentlichen
Thema des heutigen Vlogs kommen denn ich
habe mich beim Schlafen
gefilmt und das schauen wir uns jetzt
mal gemeinsam an zunächst einmal habe
ich halt die Kamera vernünftig
aufgestellt mich dann ins Bett gelegt
und halt erstmal noch ein bisschen am
Handy gechillt und dann ist erstmal
zweieinhalb Stunden nichts
passiert ich kann euch hiermer eine
timelapse davon
einblenden ich habe einfach zweh Stunden
geschlafen ich weiß auch gar nicht was
ich jetzt erwarte doch genau bei z
Stunden 39 habe ich mich dann gekratzt
blende ich euch hier mal ein ich kann
mich daran aber nicht erinnern also ich
habe das einfach wrend des Schlafens
gemacht dann sind irgendwie Helikopter
bei mir über die Wohnung
geflogen dann ist wieder eine
dreiviertel Stunde lang gar nichts
passiert einfach weiter gepennt hier
eine ganz kurze timelapse hab mich dabei
auch so ein bisschen irgendwie mit der
Decke so die Position geändert doch da
habe ich zum aller allerersten Mal einen
Laut von mir
gegeben ich habe gefurzt meine Damen und
Herren zum ersten Mal nach vi Stunden
dann habe ich plötzlich auch angefangen
zu
stöhnen und dann habe ich auch
eigentlich nur noch gepennt also hier
noch mal eine ganz kurze timelaps davon
ich bin dann irgendwann nach 6 Stunden
58 aufgewacht und bin auch einfach in
meinem völlig übermüdeten Zustand gegen
das Stativ gelaufen guten
Morgen aber gut meine Damen und Herren
das war luca hat sich beim Schlafen
gefilmt also wer hier wirklich ein
Daumen hoch gibt der ist absolut
verloren